hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of the World Chess Championship
we've had uh 14 games of classical chess
then we had three games of rapid and
this is the fourth game of Rapid if this
ends in a draw then we go into Blitz tie
breaks but as some of you have probably
already heard it might not go to blitz
so let's check out what happened here
nepo has the white pieces and he opens
with Ponte E4 and again we have Dory
Lopez with E5 Knight to a three Knights
the C6 Bishop to B5 uh and now of course
going for A6 morphe's defense Bishop to
A4 we have Knight to F6 uh castles and
the bishop to A7 so uh all standard
stuff here nothing new D3 again avoiding
the Marshall and now Pawn to B5
challenging the bishop Bishop to B3 D6
and now Pawn to A4 so uh repeating of
game two of the Rapids with uh Bishop 37
and now Ponte H3 we have castles uh and
now uh Bishop to E3 we have knighted the
A5 now going after the bishop Bishop to
A2 and now B captures an A4 so we've
already seen this in game two of the
Rapids and for those of you who are
wondering why skipped uh showing game
three it was a it was a snooze Fest you
know players just developed some pieces
agreed to a draw and moved on to game
four so now we are in game four and in
game two uh Bishop to D2 was played by
nepo which was a very
a very scary but here he just continues
with Knight to C3 we have rooked the B8
and now Bishop to B1 it looks like a
silly Square to put the bishop to uh but
nipple has very good plans for it we
have Queen to E8 and now sort of
guarding the the A4 Pawn uh but just
Pawn to B3 and here nipple shows that
you can't really capture on B3 because
the Knight on A5 would be hanging so
here just a C5 by ding uh Knight
captures an A4 and now Knight back to C6
and the situation on the clock is 24
minutes for nepo uh and 20 minutes for
ding uh and we have Knight back to C3 we
have pawned the A5 by Ding and now
Knight to D2 uh we have a bishop to E6
and now Knight the C4 just putting the
Knight on a beautiful Square here uh and
the ding strikes in the center with
Ponte D5 with e captures on D5 Knight
captures on D5 and now Bishop back to D2
you could also consider capturing hero
listen Knight captures Bishop captures
something like Pawn to F3 but nepo
decides to put the bishop on D2 like he
did in game 2 of the rapid so here
Knight captures and C3 there was a
really fun line with Knight to F4 and
then if Bishop captures on F4 you're
gonna capture an F4 uh but now you don't
really uh have the option of allowing
Bishop to F6 so you really need to move
the Knight you don't have time to pick
up the A4 A5 Pawn so you need to move
the Knight and only after Bishop to D5
or something you will play Pawn to F3
and again you get uh a really funny
position but one could only prefer black
here so that's why uh ding decided to go
Knight captures on C3 instead Bishop
captures on C3 and the bishop captures
on C4 we have B captures and C4 and now
Bishop to d8 as this line is a bit
easier to calculate so that's why I
didn't win for this one Bishop to D2 and
now Bishop to C7 the bishop is nicely
put on this diagonal at some point the
ding is hoping to execute E4 maybe some
F5 F4 action or maybe f5e for Action
maybe put a queen on the ee5 or maybe on
D6 and put pressure on that white king
So C3 by nepo and now Pawn to F5 and now
if you look at the position
uh one thing that you see that okay nepo
has the bishop pair if it becomes fully
operational then white should be better
but you also see the pass Pawn from Ding
and you also see that the bishop and B1
is pretty much completely locked in
there is no good way to
um you know revive it you can't push D4
one way to do it would be to play Bishop
to C2 and bring it to A4 this is
possible but here you simply allow for
example F4 Bishop A4 and F3 and already
it seems like uh okay what are you even
doing so instead Rook D1 was played and
now comes Rook to d8 by ding uh also if
you could try Pawn to F4 but if you play
Pawn to F4 then D4 comes and that's a
bit of an issue that's why Rook D1 stops
spawn to F4 so instead after Rook D1 we
have rooked the d8 by Ding and now Rook
the A2 by Nepal a beautiful defensive
idea and you'll see how the Rook will be
really really uh strong for the rest of
the game ding goes Bishop to G's a queen
to G6 and now the clocks have leveled
pretty much is 16 minutes for Nepal and
15 minutes for Ding and we have Queen to
E2 yeah you you could also play G3
because you know that that F4 move is
coming but uh he starts with queen T2
gets the queen out of the out of the D
file and now Queen to D6 now being
definitely preparing Sami four ideas to
maybe try and Checkmate nepo's King and
pawn to G3 and did I mention that
whoever wins this game is the world
classical champion and now Rook Dita E8
if ding pushes right away let's say with
Pawn to F4 then he allows this queen to
e for move and now it will be Nepal who
will be threatening upon the D4 because
then an attack happens against dings
King and now let's say have captors and
G3 you can even play this because Dean
will have to waste the move here not
something like Bishop to G5 and all of a
sudden
uh nipples uh position comes alive so
instead Rook D the E8 is played with
Queen to F3 and now Pawn the E4 by being
everyone thought that this was a bit
premature uh but Dingle already played
it this is like the the 70 the the 18th
Game In This World Chess Championship uh
he knows what he's doing D captures an
E4 and now I didn't paused a little bit
here because okay you know that Knight
the E5 is the move you want to play but
he was considering Ponte F4 here and it
is a beautiful line that we should check
point is that after Bishop captures you
will move the queen and now uh nipple
will be in some problems here for
example Queen to E3 you will capture an
F4 nonetheless G captures Queen to H6 uh
you are putting a lot of pressure on
White's position here also if the Rook
somehow gets into the attack could be
very nasty so let's say Pawn to F5 you
off for a queen trade but now Rook
captures an F5 first because the Rook
cannot be captured and now even if
Queens get traded off uh The Rook still
cannot be captured so probably something
like Rook to E3 Now The Rook moves and
the game continues but ding decided
against it he played Knights the E5
attack nipples Queen here Queen to G2
uh and now Knight to D3 very very sharp
stuff uh Naples Queen not that active on
on the G2 Square uh but Bishop captures
and D3 is a must so while Knight to D3
is a beautiful move and you really feel
great when you play it uh basically this
bishop has been dead for for the entire
game and now you're allowing him to to
basically trade this bishop for for this
beautiful Knight but okay Bishop
captures Queen characters on D3 you gain
a lot more activity with your queen he
captures an F5 Rook captures anyone with
check Bishop captures and now Queen
captures and C4 and now uh nipple plays
a rook to A1 there was a really tricky
maneuver he Rook to D2 yeah because if
you if you capture here then you allow
the White Queen out of the box here
Queen to D5 check and maybe it's good to
give up that pawn to sort of make your
position come alive a little bit uh but
okay uh in the game never played Rook to
A1 and now we have Rook captures on F5
uh nipple has 12 minutes on the clock
and Dink has uh some 5 minutes and 30
seconds on the clock uh Bishop to D2 We
have Pawn to H6 and now Queen to C6 very
active move from nepo activating his
Queen we have Rook to F7 the bishop has
to be defended but also you want to keep
pressure on that F2 pawn and now comes
Rook to E1 now nepo is the one who's
threatening to
as there's some trouble if you allow
Rook d8 with check it could be it could
be very nasty so here you could play
Queen to D3 sort of to pressure the
bishop and also to keep an eye on this
diagonal so even if a check happens uh
you don't have to worry about a second
check coming along this diagonal but the
thing goes uh King to H7 first and now
we have Bishop to E3 now the point was
that if you play Rook to E8 then ding
had in mind the shop captures on G3 and
you can't capture back because if you
capture back Queen to F1 check and you
are getting checkmated Rook F2 check uh
Queen has the block and now queen or
Rook captures will be Checkmate so
instead after this uh King to H7 move we
have Bishop to E3 putting pressure on
the C5 Pawn but now Bishop to E5 then
puts pressure on the C3 pawn and now
everyone thought we would just see a
trade here if Queen captures on C5 Queen
captures and C5 Bishop captures and C5
Bishop captures and C3 attacks the rook
and you have this end game equal
material it will probably
end up in a draw but nipple wanted more
he played Queen to E8 and now you have
to be very very careful here you can't
really move the queen or The Rook hangs
if you don't do anything then the bishop
hangs so ding played Bishop captures on
C3 and now comes Rook to C1 so now
nipple has to be very careful he's not
just on a pawn uh he he he's he's down
upon but also ding has two passed pawns
so if this doesn't work could be
incredibly dangerous uh Rook to F6
biting he shows that he is not worried
about Bishop to D2 and he calculated
well if Bishop to D2 then look at this
queen to D4 puts pressure on F2 and now
nipple gets nothing more than a draw
Bishop campers Queen captures an F2 King
to H1 and this will now result in a draw
by rep Edition Queen F3 checking which
do have to check King F1 Queen to F3
check and so on so after Rook to F6 uh
nipple played Queen to D7 to keep the
the tension keep the game going now
comes Queen to E2 by ding beautiful spot
by ding sing that if you capture my
Bishop I'm going to play Queen E1 check
and capture The Rook here this seemed
like all uh you know simple tactics but
players were extremely low on time here
so Queen to D5 uh and now comes a bishop
to B4 ding just guards the pawns here
and he says what what are you playing
now because if you capture on C5 ding
again found this beautiful Bishop to E1
tactic and now the only way to defend is
to play this passive Queen to G2 move
and now you will uh position your pieces
properly and start pushing that a pawn
with all of this pressure being applied
to the F2 Pawn so after Bishop B4 we
have Queen to E4 with check uh King to
G8 and now Queen to D5 with check and I
think at this point Nepal already saw
the repetition he said all right now
we're just gonna repeat moves King H7
Queen T for checking Jade Queen to D5
check however after King to H7 and queen
T4 check ding did not move the King Ding
played Rook to G6 and everyone thought
this was crazy because how do you
release the Rook from this grip
and also what about H4 H5 well that's
the point h4h5 isn't really a threat
because uh Queen to F5 was played if you
play H4 ding just plays H5 and there's
no continuation here so never played
Queen to F5 now putting more pressure on
that C5 Pawn but now ding plays Pawn to
C4 he just starts pushing his pass pawn
and here we have Pawn to H4 by nepo uh
Queen to F4 was still sort of an attempt
at fighting but after H4 the position is
now winning for ding so I'm even gonna
give you a chance to win the game for
then feel free to pause the video and
win the game find the absolute best move
for Dean while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on spotting the
tactic that might win you the title of
world classical champion and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Queen to D3 this is the absolute
best move and the point is that you
cannot trade if you trade here let's
take captures captures uh Rook to D1
okay you've uh survived a little bit but
after Rook the D6 this Pawn is coming to
D2 and then this Pawn marches forward
and it will be unstoppable so after
Queen to D3 nipple played Queen to F3
but now comes Rook to F6 attacking the
queen here Queen to G4 and not Pawn to
C3 dings pawns are Marching forward we
have Rook the D1 attacking the queen now
Queen to G6 beautiful and again you
can't trade queens and if you play
something like Queen to C8 which was
played in the game you could also try
Queen to C4 doesn't really matter The
Rook is coming to C6 and will help with
the advancement of the C Pawn so Queen
the C8 was played now comes Rook the C6
we have Queen to A8 and now uh neposoto
sets a little trap here foreign because
everything continues with C2 then this
was what nepo had in mind Rook to C1 and
after Bishop to A3 he had in mind Rook
to E1 and if now C1 Queen he had in mind
the bishop captures and after Rook
captures Rook captures and Bishop
captures he will play Queen captures on
A5 and okay he will be uh down a piece
but he will probably probably draw this
so ding said nope I'm not even allowing
that he played Rook to D6 and now we
have Rook captures on D6 Queen captures
on D6 and queen to E4 with check we have
Queen to G6 now stopping and queen to C4
with uh Queen to B1 with Chuck King to
H2 and now Pawn to A4 uh ding now
continues to push his past eighth a pawn
bishop to D4 and now even Pawn to A3 so
offering the opponent C3 and there was
uh there was a way for nepot to play a
wonderful move here Bishop captures and
G7 would go a long way because after
King characters and queen to D4 check
there is no way for the black king to
get out checks but I think nepo was
still actually trying to win this game
here even maybe Queen the C7 was played
and now ding just goes back with Queen
to G6 now his King is safe and he can
continue pushing the pawns and now the
problem is if you capture on C3 then
look at this bishop captures Queen
characters and after Pawn 32 yes you are
guarding the queening square but there's
Quinta after any move that white makes
there's Queen to B1 and there's no
defense against queening the pawn and
you have no checks as the black queen
nicely controls this diagonal so Queen
to C4 was played now comes Punta C2 the
pawn is nicely defended here Bishop to
E3 but now Bishop to D6 there's no way
out of this uh King to G2 both players
were now below the one minute Mark and
now comes Ponte H5 by Ding King to F1
with Bishop to E5 leaving yarn with no
Contra play Ponto G4 Yana has to go all
out or otherwise he can just resign H
characters and G4 we have H5 and now
Queen to F5 of course not allow Gyan to
grab the C2 pawn queen to D5 and now
Pawn to G3 even Jan's position is now
falling apart as are his dreams of
becoming World classical Champion Ponte
F4 with Ponte A2 with Queen characters
on A2 Nepal new now he he made a really
sad face a little bit the other way and
he you know came to turns to terms with
the fact that he will not be becoming
world champion he grabbed the pawn ding
played Bishop captures on F4 and he was
in this position on move 68 that Yani
Punisher resigned to the game and after
four rapid games it is dingler and who
is becoming who has become World
classical champion and that's it this is
the end of an era Magnus held the title
for for 11 years but now it is ding's
time ding is now World classical
champion and we'll see what happens uh
next in the in the world of Chess so it
was uh an absolutely incredible match I
mean everyone thought that okay Yan is
just too strong ding is
um losing too much in classical then
ding always bonds back then Yan took the
lead again then dingbound back the neon
to the lead again ding bonds back and
then you know in the Rapids you've seen
what happened here so okay you could
argue once again that a world classical
Champion was decided in Rapid chess and
even if this game was drawn that a world
classical Champion would be decided in
uh Blitz chess even but no the world
classical Champion was decided over the
course of a whole month over the course
of uh 14 classical games uh and for
Rapid games so that's basically so okay
so maybe it's not the clean classical
Champion but what what we get here is a
universal world champion of the sort if
you will uh so yeah here you resign
because you're getting checkmated
whatever you play let's say you you try
sidestepping just Bishop captures on E3
and that's it you remove the defender of
the of the C1 Square you get another
queen next move you get checkmated and
that's it regardless of what you play
every Everything ends with Checkmate
here uh so uh here uh I even have a nice
image of it for you guys to enjoy
because this is this is the image that
we've seen uh when Magnus Carlsen became
world champion I know you guys remember
it because it's a really famous photo
there you have it this is Magnus jumping
in the pool after he defeated
and he published on his Twitter profile
that he is he has become world champion
and that he thanks everyone for the
support I don't know if ding will be
jumping in the pool but the next video
I'll be making if there will be a nice
photo of ding I will definitely share it
with you guys uh so there we have it
thank you for uh for you know enjoying
uh the the World Chess Championship
thank you for enjoying chess in general
for for promoting just your friends and
for you know uh sticking with just for
for the past month as this has been uh
quite a journey even with uh Magnus
Carlsen stepping down uh from you know
uh defending his title as the world
classical champion this has been an an
incredible month and I have no idea what
the future holds if Magnus will be
trying to come back will they be
changing the the format a little bit uh
or will we just keep you know everything
the same and we'll just have another
candidates tournament with someone to
challenge Dean we'll see what happens
but whatever happens uh you know that we
we will uh at least once every two years
we will have a month filled with chess
uh where you know we're just filled with
beautiful games and we can enjoy every
day uh so yeah who knows what the future
brings uh we'll see what happens until
then hope you guys are still enjoying
chess uh so yeah that's the game and
this short coverage of the World Chess
Championship hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank all
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing at the checkup on your
wonderful suggestions and everything
else that happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day